SHARAD JONES: Hey,
everyone, welcome back.
So in this last topic to
talk about this semester,
I wanted to take a little
bit of a different direction.
So this will be a
little bit different
of a lecture than the previous
ones, and for that matter,
may end up being a bit
shorter because there's
a lot of open-ended questions.
But I wanted to start it
with this open ended question
of, why shouldn't
I use the cloud?
And here when I'm
saying the cloud,
I'm talking about the way
we've been treating the cloud.
We've been treating
the cloud as a suite
of tools available through
some large cloud provider.
We focused on specifically AWS.
But in reality, we could
have been talking about any
of the other cloud providers.
So we could have been
talking about Google Cloud
Project, Microsoft Azure.
But either way, are there
situations where I, maybe,
don't want to be looking at
one of those cloud providers?
And it's not to say again
that their tools aren't
good, or reasonable, or we
shouldn't consider them.
But I want us to recognize
that the internet we
see today, this cloud-based
internet, and again, cloud
being large cloud
provider-based internet,
this is merely a byproduct of
history, but it's not by any
means the way it has
to be, in the future.
It very much could be this.
This is a lecture
that I hesitated
to do even because
I'm here trying
to not necessarily
predict the future,
but better statement, just
say the future is a bit open.
And you all are going to be the
next generation of developers,
and cloud engineers and, data
scientists, and data analysts,
and for that matter,
any job you go into.
You're just the future
of internet users.
And so I want you to think
about this as far as,
what do you want your
internet to look like,
and what do you think the
internet should or shouldn't
look like?
And so I just
wanted to introduce
some of these ideas
and maybe a case study
to motivate why I kind of
came to do this lecture.
So first off, I want to talk
about, what is the cloud?
So the cloud, in
its simplest form,
can be viewed as-- or
better, this quote here
from this article that we'll
talk about in a second.
And you can see it there
on the bottom of the page.
But this article gave
this quote that I
think is a good summary of
why we should use the cloud.
So "The cloud excels at
two ends of the spectrum.
The first end is when your
application is so simple and low
traffic that you really do
save on complexity by starting
with fully managed services.
The second is when your
load is highly irregular,
when you have wild swings or
towering peaks and usages,
when the baseline is a
sliver of your largest needs,
or when you have no idea whether
you need 10 servers or 100."
So that, I think,
really summarizes
what we've talked
about this semester.
How do we build tools
and applications
that scale with wildly
different needs and usages?
And so I want you to think,
what are some businesses that
fall into that
first category, that
fall into the side of things
where maybe your application is
so simple?
Really, you're not worried
about the big swings and usages
right now.
You're just saying, I
have a simple product.
What are some examples of that?
Maybe pause and
think about that.
I know what I'll say is that I
think about a tool like Heroku.
Heroku allowed us to build
our flask application.
And with one or two
lines on the terminal,
we could push our
app to run live.
And now it's hosted.
We don't have to deal with any
of the management of servers
or anything like that.
We just have a live
web application
with a URL attached to it
publicly accessible URL.
That's outstanding.
I think that's a
huge number of tools
that we can build that
fall into that bucket.
For that matter, I
hope you all have
thought about this semester, all
the cool things you could build.
And we've only built very,
very simple applications.
But you're now
effectively empowered
to build any web app
you want to and push
it live via one of
these tools, with most
of them even having free tiers.
But even beyond that, if you're
building an application, maybe
for, I don't know,
your class you're
in, or maybe even
for a company--
you're working for a small
business, a local business,
and they don't have an
inventory system or an inventory
management system.
And you want to build
a simple version of one
for them that has a
nice web interface.
Well, great.
You can do that,
host it on Heroku.
You know you're only going
to have one, maybe two users,
the people working in there.
So you're not really worried
about costs or anything
like that.
But you don't really
want to spend time
on the management side.
That's an outstanding use case
for cloud-based tools, again,
these large cloud providers.
So what about the
second category, then?
So that's the category
where your load
is highly irregular-- wild
swings, towering peaks
and usages, don't know if
you need 10 servers or 100.
What are some examples of that?
And the reason I want
you to think about this
is going to potentially
impact or be
something you have
to consider when
you arrive at a new company.
Again, you may be put into
a developer role or a data
science-type role.
And all of a sudden you're
building applications
that maybe they're going out
to the users of your website.
Are the users of your website
going to hit this sporadically?
Is it going to be
all of a sudden
when you launch the
product live, everybody's
going to spike on
it for the first day
and then after that,
it's going to taper?
What are the needs going to be?
Is it going to be
cyclical, where maybe you--
maybe you're putting out some
sort of really interesting
newsletter?
If you think about
that, or your company
has some sort of monthly
brief that they do,
and you know that
every month, you
could have a swing where
you all of a sudden need
a bunch of servers for that
immediate burst of readership,
and then it just trickles
for the rest of the month.
In that place, you
can really leverage
against some of
these tools where
I don't have to worry about
auto-scaling-- or scaling
my servers.
I don't have to build
up more capacity.
I don't have to have capacity
for the theoretical peak usage.
I can just get it
for when I need,
or when I basically fall
in, or when I actually
have that monthly demand.
And so that's very much the
thing you want to think about,
or where you may want
to leverage cloud tools
is when you fall into
that second bucket.
Now, the third question
I have there, I think,
is a bit more subtle.
And you might have to take
some time to think on this.
But this is the meaningful
one, I think, for this lecture
at least, and potentially for,
again, the way the internet
may go.
Are there situations, are
there businesses, maybe,
entirely that don't fall
into either these categories?
Don't need a simple application.
They have the resources
and the talent
necessary to build and
maintain applications,
so they don't really need
the fully managed services.
And on the other
end of the spectrum,
they don't really have really
irregular peaks and usages.
It's pretty
consistent user base.
So think about
those for a second.
Now, I'll give you an example of
that here with this one company.
And so there's a
parent company here
that holds both the
product HEY and Bandcamp--
or sorry, not
Bandcamp, Basecamp.
I've got a little typo there.
But Basecamp is a project
management platform.
So if you've used any
project management platforms,
like Jira-type ones, Trello
even, some of the features
are really Trello-esque in
there, that's what Basecamp is.
It's a project
management platform.
HEY is a different
product entirely
that this company built.
And it's an email service.
It's a pretty cool
email service.
I haven't personally used it.
But they've got some
new interesting features
that I think make an argument
to potentially switch to it
or at least try it out.
They have a screening
feature where
you get to choose which emails
you will or won't receive.
So rather than having
just an inbox where
you decide what you're going
to delete, or maybe block,
or report, you
instead get a kind
of pre-screening feature
where you just say yes/no,
yes/no on all the, or on the new
emails or new senders coming in.
Then they also have
three separate inboxes.
So I use Gmail for
my personal email.
And so I'm used to Inbox and
maybe Primary and Social--
or sorry, Promotions and
Social, which is maybe OK dump.
But for the most part, I only
care about things in the inbox.
Promotions, I rarely look at.
Those are just ads.
And social, I don't also
care about notifications
from social media websites.
So it's not really
a meaningful Inbox.
But here they break it
into three different ones.
So one is the Imbox,
I-M, and that's
for immediate reads, things that
they think are high-priority,
need to read these ASAP.
Then there's The Feed, which
is your non-urgent emails.
And I think about this as,
that would be these promotions
and social potentially
lumped together,
newsletters, other things
that aren't urgent,
but maybe you want
to see or look at.
And then finally,
The Paper Trail,
where it's infrequent access.
So receipts, confirmation,
all that kind of stuff
would fall into the paper
trail where I don't even
need to see that it
came into the Inbox.
But I need to search
it, or have the ability
to search it later on.
Either way, a bunch
of other features,
Reply later, all kinds
of other cool stuff.
But that's not the
point of this lecture.
It's just to say that they have
these two products Basecamp
and HEY.
And Basecamp especially, it
is a product for businesses.
It's a product for
project management.
So they have a very
stable user base.
They're not getting wild swings.
These companies, when they
get onto a project management
platform, they're not
trying a bunch of them,
and dropping them, and
adding them back on.
They usually lock
onto one and keep
that for a pretty long stretch
of time, at least a year-plus,
usually.
And also, they're not getting
a bunch of new users on either.
There are so many
competitors in this space
that they can have their niche.
They can grow.
But it's a very stable growth.
It's not going to be
these huge spikes.
HEY, on the other
hand, did actually
have a pretty strong growth
in the first few months of it.
They got some good
press that drove them.
I think I even remember
seeing some of the early press
from them.
But that drove a lot more users
than they expected initially.
And so they really were
able to leverage AWS
specifically to grow fast, to
adapt really fast to the growing
demands of their users.
But eventually, they stabilized,
and they're kind of in that boat
now.
And this is what motivated
them to write this article.
So the article that was
linked on the last page
is from hey.com there.
And it was their CEO.
And he mentioned there
that they were spending
over half a million dollars per
year for database and search
through AWS.
And so that is really
the question is,
if I'm spending already half a
million dollars, is that worth
it?
Is half a million
dollars per year--
and these are
businesses that have
been around for a
couple of years now.
So their spending on the
order of millions of dollars,
is that worth it?
And so I pulled out these
two quotes from the article
that I thought were
pretty interesting.
So first he said, "We've seen
all the cloud has to offer,
and tried most of it.
It's finally time to conclude
renting computers is mostly
a bad deal for
medium-sized companies,
like ours with stable growth.
The savings promised in reduced
complexity never materialized."
Man, that is a word I
struggle with, "materialized."
"So we're making
our plans to leave."
And then the second quote
is, "Now the argument always
goes, sure, but you have
to manage these costs--
or these machines.
The cloud is so much simpler.
The savings will all be
there in labor costs!
Except no.
Anyone who thinks running
a major service like HEY
or Basecamp in the cloud is
simple has clearly never tried.
Some things are simpler,
others more complex.
But on the whole, I've yet
to hear what organizations
at our scale being able
to materially shrink
their operations team
just because they moved
to the cloud."
And that's kind of-- again,
this article was actually
the motivation for this lecture,
is that this is a reality.
The new cycle is
probably dominated
mostly by very large companies
or companies, better statement,
that had meteoric growth.
For example, my time at Carvana,
in the time span I was there--
I think I started in 2014, late
2014, there was about 30 or 40
of us.
By the time I left in
2017, there was over 1,500.
And at their peak,
there was over 25,000.
So the growth there was
exponential, to say the least.
And that was a situation
where only have the choice
to leverage cloud resources.
And that was just
talking employee growth.
But basically, employee growth
was tracking with sales.
And so it was just
managing all the users.
And traffic would
have been completely
incomprehensible with
buying new servers
because every month
changed things.
And for that matter,
the pandemic really
changed things for a company
like that where all of a sudden
there was a huge rush
of users that didn't
want to go into dealerships.
And so now, we need to scale--
or they need to
scale accordingly
to handle all the new users that
could potentially be coming on.
And so something like AWS is
just invaluable in that case.
And so again, this is not to
say those aren't good tools.
But there are a lot, if not
arguably more companies,
that are falling more
into this bucket of what
HEY and Basecamp are dealing
with where they're having
success, they are generating
revenue, they are paying
their employees, and
enjoying some growth,
but for the most part.
They're not seeing
this meteoric growth.
They're not seeing these
constant swings in user bases.
And so for them, it's kind
of expensive, half a million
dollars per year.
And that was the argument.
We've done a lot of different
things in the cloud so far.
But we haven't even scraped
the surface, honestly,
of all the things you can do.
And you already have seen how
many technical difficulties
and unique things you have to
learn and all the menus you
have to go through.
For that matter,
by construction,
one of the motivations
for this course
again, was the AWS
cloud certification.
Well, by construction,
having a certification
to say that you
understand the cloud that
requires multiple classes and
years of effort to learn to
implies that this is
not a simple thing.
This doesn't mean
that you necessarily
don't have to have
employees to use the cloud.
For that matter-- again,
I remember when we first
started bringing on AWS or using
AWS, we hired on more people
to manage that.
It wasn't that all of a
sudden we let people go.
We needed more people
that knew what they
were doing with regard to AWS.
And so that's the reality of it.
It's not necessarily
that it's going
to overall reduce
the labor costs,
at least not in every case.
And that was their argument,
is that for half a million
dollars per year, we can invest
up front in servers and server
capacity that we need.
And then we can
also pay employees.
We can hire on a person or
two to manage these resources,
to allocate and provision
resources to users.
We'll talk plenty
about the tools
that are available to do this.
But there's tons of
software out there
to handle all these
tasks that we need to do.
And so maybe we
don't necessarily
need one of these big cloud
providers to support us.
And so on that note, let's
talk about some of these tools,
some of the alternatives
to using the cloud.
And I think the first
and most important
thing to consider is that
the vast majority of work
we did, and also in general
that most people use AWS for,
is EC2 and S3, spinning
up EC2 instances
and storing things in the cloud.
And so EC2 really
gives us the benefit
of being able to quickly scale
up the number of instances,
or the size of
instances quickly.
And so the questions we need to
think to ourselves are, well,
how quickly do we need
to our capacity increase?
And how large is the largest
instance you'll need?
If you can answer
those two questions
and the answer to
the first one maybe
isn't that, I need to always
have-- or better statement,
the answer to both questions
isn't that I don't really know,
and that I have a
wide range of needs.
If that's not your
answer to that question,
then by all means,
EC2 instances are just
a matter of having
a bunch of computers
sitting there that
your users can access.
So imagine you're a company, and
you have a bunch of employees,
and maybe you work on some
sensitive access tools.
And so you don't want
to have your employees
have this software
on their laptops.
Well, they still need to
be able to have laptops.
They need to be able to
move around the office
and maybe even work
remotely sometimes.
And so one option is to
have physical computers,
large physical computers,
that are our servers really,
that are located in some
server room at your office,
or at a remote location, or even
have in different locations.
You could have provide
each of your employees
with laptops that
have a VPN that allow
them to VPN into your network.
And then they can use a
tool like Remote Desktop,
a Windows-based
tool-- and we'll talk
about what remote desktop is.
But it basically just allows
them to remotely connect
to this computer.
Or alternatively, maybe
they have varying needs
and resources.
And you want to be able to
allow them to share resources
amongst each other.
You don't want to just allocate
a whole computer to one person,
but you want to say like,
hey, sometimes person
A needs this much, and
person B needs this much.
And then they switch or swap.
And so in that
case, then, well, I
can look at, using
virtual machines.
And that's effectively
what EC2 instances are.
There is a computer
that's sitting out there
or a server that's
sitting out there.
Any hypervisor, it's
a software layer
that sits on top of the
computer, on top of the server.
And that hypervisor allows
you to allocate and manage
the resources for each user.
And we'll talk a little
bit about that as well.
But first on the remote
desktop protocol side,
if you haven't used this
before, this is a Microsoft--
It's, a proprietary
Microsoft tool.
But there's plenty of
equivalence out there.
But the simplest-- the nice
thing about it is a really
simple framework where all I
have to do is pass in the--
oh, gosh, word slip
in my head-- the URL
or the IP address of the
computer of interest here
and then also any sort of
relevant login information.
So if I have specific
login information here,
I can pass that into the
username or password.
But either way, once I do
that and click Connect,
what I'm actually
doing is physically
connecting to this
remote server.
And this is a bit
different than what
we've been doing
where we've just
been SSHing into remote server.
Here, you're physically given
mouse and keyboard access.
So you will open
up a window that
just looks like you're
on a Windows desktop,
but you're on this
computers windows desktop,
even though you're accessing
it from this computer.
And so this allows you, again,
to easily connect two machines
and allow your users to
work from wherever they need
to assuming they have
a secure connection
and connect to remote computers.
Constrains all
business processes.
You can run them on-premise.
These servers can be on-premise.
You don't have to
worry about that.
You can give your users access
to really large computers.
And this is how
I've used them is
that I've had-- maybe
our team would have
a specific remote computer that
ran everything and also has
the benefit of staying
online all the time.
So if there's any sort of stored
procedures or stuff like that,
I can run them on here because
it's going to stay live.
This is also another way,
and this is something
that I've done to some extent.
And if we had more time
this semester, maybe
we would get into this.
But if you're saying,
hey, I'm going
into this world of data
science or software development
and I really need a
large computer because I
have varying needs as far as
RAM goes, or better statement,
I need a lot of RAM, I need
a lot of compute power,
maybe I need a GPU to do
my deep learning research--
Well, rather than having
to buy a laptop that
has all of the hardware
necessary in it to handle
your workload, which
is almost never
going to be a good laptop--
There are definitely
benefits to it,
but there's always a trade-off.
So if I buy a big, beefy
programming computer,
it'll be great at that.
But it's going to be heavy, and
it's going to get really hot,
and it's going to be expensive.
And it also arguably
is just not going
to be as good or as efficient
as a large computer.
The cost is going to be so much
higher for the performance.
So instead, I can buy a
cheaper, big desktop tower.
That's why this shows
as a tower here.
I can buy a big one of these,
have this sitting at my house.
And then I could just remotely
connect to my own computer
at my house.
I could open up a Remote
Desktop connection such
that I can access my
own computer at home.
And so this is a really
cool thing now is,
you could keep this the same.
You could upgrade it every
year as you need new parts,
and whatnot, or
need more capacity.
But your laptop itself
doesn't really matter.
This is just going
to be whatever you
need to use on a daily basis.
Sorry, my dog just walked in.
And so that's kind of the
idea behind the Remote Desktop
protocol.
And so then going on
to the hypervisor,
so the hypervisor is--
again, like I said, this is a
much more how Amazon does it
with their EC2 instances.
So these EC2 instances
sit on some hardware.
The hardware is
the server itself.
And then the hypervisor
allocates the resources
to the individual users.
And really, the hypervisor is
providing an operating system,
a full-on operating
system, to that user,
such that, again, they
could SSH into it,
or you could even have them do a
Remote Desktop connection to it.
But it's being managed by this.
So you're basically giving
them virtual hardware access.
And so there's two types of
these, not really important
for this class.
But just so you
know that you can
have type 1 hypervisors
that operate directly
on the hardware level.
So they sit just
above the hardware
before the operating
system is even in place.
They are allocating the
operating system to the users.
And that usually has
speed, latency benefits,
and all that good
stuff, and also
just is a lighter weight, too.
I don't have to have
as much software.
I'm not limited on what
hypervisor can use,
or better statement, I'm not
limited on what the operating
system has available to it,
since I'm operating directly
on the hardware.
Type 2 is sitting on
an operating system.
So there exists an
operating system.
So this is like me running
Windows on my computer,
then having a hypervisor
that's running on my Windows
machine, that then is allocating
operating systems to the user.
And these operating
systems don't necessarily
have to be the same as
this base operating system.
It just depends on whatever your
architecture and the hypervisor
supports.
But this now is an,
or better statement,
this is just an alternative.
And there are just more
type 2 than type 1.
But there is even a type I
open source hypervisor called
Xen Project.
It's part of the
Linux Foundation.
And so again, you
could download--
you could have your
own server at home.
You could download
this hypervisor,
run this hypervisor
on that server
and allocate your resources
to all the users in your home.
So maybe your family has
varying compute needs.
And so you could
build a home server
that allocates
resources as necessary
or as requested by your
family to use on the--
or to use those
different computers.
And that brings me
to the next one.
So these are more--
this is just a little
bit more of a fun idea.
It's a little bit different from
what we've been talking about.
But this idea of home-labbing
is growing pretty significantly.
And the exact idea
behind this is just, hey,
what if I built my own cloud
computing platform at home?
What if I had my
own cloud at home?
And all these images are pulled
from the r/HomeLab subreddit.
So you can check that out if
you're interested in this topic
at all.
And it does require, again,
a lot of hardware experience,
and costs can get
really expensive.
But they can also stay low, too.
Right here, this on the
bottom right hand side
is a set of four Raspberry Pis
running as a Kubernetes cluster.
So serving-- you can basically--
Kubernetes is a container
orchestration service.
And so I could have
my Docker containers,
a bunch of Docker
applications that
could run directly off
of this cluster here.
It just has cooling
pipes coming into it.
So it's a pretty
cool little setup.
It wouldn't cost you too
much, assuming you could get--
Raspberry Pis are a little
hard to find these days.
But assuming you get those, you
could do this for really cheap
and have technically your
own little server at home.
This is a cloud computing
cluster connected
to your internet network.
It has high-speed connections
running between any of these.
So they're all going to be
able to share information
very quickly.
And so you can have
a full-on server
just from this little thing,
or you could get really intense
and have a big server rack here.
And this is a diagram of
some of these smart home
setup that's all based on this.
And that's one of
the common use cases
for home lab setups is
just smart home management.
But you can use it as
a home media server.
So if you have a bunch of
movies, and photos, and stuff,
well, rather than me paying
for S3 cloud storage,
I could just buy the
physical storage space here,
manage it myself, and I could
have all my Google Photos there.
I can have an
internet connected.
And so rather than
having Google Photos,
I just have my photos folders
which are internet connected.
I can access them from my phone,
my laptop, whatever I want.
And yeah, it'll require
a lot of effort on my end
and probably cost on my end.
But it's also non-trivial.
It's not cheap to have
cloud resources either.
And so it's, just again, depends
on what your interests are.
It's not to say that everybody
or anybody really needs
to build a full home lab setup.
But if you are interested
in the hardware side of it,
it's kind of a fun way to do it.
It's a really great
resume booster.
You can talk about what you've
actually done, how you've
actually built server racks.
I think that'll impress
some companies, for sure.
So that's out there as far as--
and I also provided a few links
as far as other things you
can do with them and some more
resources.
But the moral of
the story is, again,
that the tools to do what we
do in the cloud, the aspects
of those tools, we can
do those ourselves.
There exist open
source alternatives.
And for that matter,
as you continue
to build your education, you
can start to build these tools
and really, again,
build a different type
of internet for yourself.
It's not to say there's
anything wrong with the internet
today, right or wrong, but it's
just that I want you always
to remain open to the
different opportunities that
may exist out there.
It's always hard to
say on the outset what
the next iteration of the
internet is going to look like.
But it's important to stay open
to new ideas and new potentials
for the future.
And so that kind of brings
us then to this big picture.
So one more quote from that
article that I mentioned before.
But they said, "But this
isn't just about cost.
It's also about what
kind of internet
we want to operate
in the future.
It strikes me as
downright tragic
that this decentralized
wonder of the world
is now largely operating
on computers owned
by a handful of corporations.
If one of the primary
AWS regions goes down,
seemingly half the internet
is offline with it.
This is not what
DARPA designed."
And they're not
wrong, to some extent.
We've all experienced
this whenever
all of a sudden, Netflix doesn't
work. amazon.com doesn't work.
Twitter, Facebook,
all these sites
go down that we access daily.
And it feels like, what happened
that half of the internet
just shut off then?
To some extent, it's
because we have heavily
centralized our internet.
I think the last time I looked
something like 30-something
percent of internet traffic
is running through AWS.
And the rest of
it being allocated
to the other major cloud
providers for the most part.
And so this is the
big consideration
is, what does that mean for
us, both from a standpoint
of a usability, but
also then opportunity?
What does the
centralized internet
allow that a potential
decentralized internet doesn't
allow?
So yeah, I want you
to think about this.
And these three
questions, I really
don't have answers to them.
So I'm not going to
be able to give you
the nice, clean-cut
lecture answer to these.
But what are the downsides
of centralizing internet
to a few large players?
What are some of the blockers to
actually decentralizing, then,
if we prefer to go
the other direction,
and they are easier to overcome?
And I think those two questions
are the fundamental question
to at least how the
infrastructure of the internet
will look in the near future.
Because these are the
two major decisions that,
or the two major things we've
been playing with in industry
is centralizing heavily
to a few major players,
streamlines things, make sure
or ensures interoperability,
but comes at the cost of are at
the will of the large players.
And also, does it
reduce the opportunity?
Does it reduce the
ingenuity, the inventiveness
of all the technologies
we have out there?
Does it constrain us to
only build what Amazon has,
allowing us to build.
All these kind of things, I
think, just really open up
more opportunities.
And that's where I
think the major benefit
of the decentralizing
of the internet is,
is that it opens up the
door to every small player
in the space to build a new,
interesting, innovative tool
that didn't really
exist or couldn't really
exist with a heavily
centralized internet.
But I think the major
downsides, then,
are the difficulties
are, well, how
do we ensure interoperability?
How do I ensure that
I can easily discover
and manage and support.
How do I ensure
that it's equitable?
How do I ensure that we
have equitable access
to cloud computing resources?
We talked a bit about
this at the beginning
that Amazon's not
perfect either at this,
but at least, they
have the resources
to leverage the economies of
scale, and all that good stuff.
So I don't know if there's
a clear-cut answer to which
direction things will go.
But I want you to be open
and explore opportunities
in either direction.
One interesting one
that's been in the news
a lot recently, as far as
towards decentralization goes,
is Mastodon.
So obviously,
we're sitting here,
this video at least
recorded in late 2022.
And so Twitter is going
through a transformative time,
to say the least.
And that's obviously
putting a lot of--
or shining a lot
of light on, well,
what are the downsides or risks
of us having centralized, again,
our internet or our
microblogging communications
to a few major apps,
a few major players?
And so Mastodon
encourages an alternative.
It is a decentralized
social media platform.
And also, full disclosure, I
do not have a Mastodon account.
I am not pushing for Mastodon.
I have no interest or stake
in their future success.
But I think it proposes
an interesting alternative
to these, and that's
why I'm introducing it.
But either way, what they mean
by decentralized social media
platform is that the
software for Mastodon,
the actual underlying code,
is completely open source.
And what that means then is that
you can host your own Mastodon
server on whatever
resources you want to.
You could do it
on AWS resources,
or you could do it on a
set of Raspberry Pis you
have sitting at your house.
And that server, as long as
it's connected to the internet,
can still connect to and
follow other accounts
that are on different servers.
For that matter, you could have
your friends all share a server,
but then remotely connect
to-- or follow other accounts
on other servers.
So it still looks like
a single feed to you.
But the actual location or
the source of the information
is coming from
different locations.
This ensures, then,
that, well, whatever
happens with the overarching
platform isn't technically going
to directly impact your server.
If the entirety of Mastodon
shut down tomorrow,
everybody who has
a Mastodon account
could still maintain
their Mastodon account
because all of the software
to run a Mastodon server
is open source.
So there is no location where
it's just sitting there,
is the main source of the code.
The entirety of
Mastodon can't go down
without the entirety of
the internet going down.
And that adds, again,
some redundancy,
some reliability,
but also again,
allows for a lot of new
ideas and new way of sharing
information to exist.
Think about, again,
maybe there's
a news agency that
is posting news
that, whether you
agree with it or not,
is potentially
subject to censoring.
Maybe I'm in a location
where the news--
if I'm in an
authoritarian regime
that limits what I can share.
Well, my Mastodon server,
outside of them blocking access
to the internet
for me, could share
whatever it wanted to
still because there's
no centralized platform
it's going through.
They can't go to Twitter and
say, hey, don't share this.
They can't go to Facebook and
Now, this does mean
that content moderation
is left to independent servers.
But the benefit of that is--
and you'll see if you visit
their website--
that most servers have an
application requirement.
So you can't just
immediately set up an account
and reach everybody
that's on that server.
They have to specifically
choose to include you
in their communications.
And so that's really,
again, the major benefit
that I see from it.
But I'd love you
to think about some
of the pros and cons of, again,
decentralizing social media
platform because not
everything is rosy,
and it doesn't always
work out perfect.
Everything has pros and cons.
And so keep that in
mind and think on that.
And then, I'll just
end on this last slide
of just talking more generically
of the decentralized internet.
We've given an example
of Mastodon here.
But what if every
website and every service
was like Mastodon,
completely decentralized,
running on all kinds
of disparate servers?
And that's really the idea
behind this idea of Web3,
this idea of Web3 has
heavily been taken over
by discussion of
cryptocurrency and NFTs.
And that's very much not
what I am interested in,
nor talking about here.
That is built on a technology,
this blockchain technology,
that conceivably
could and likely will
be a big part of a
decentralized internet.
But I view those as
separate entities.
And unfortunately,
they've kind of
been relegated to that,
since they've become
these speculative investments.
So it's a very
different concept,
not what I'm talking about here.
Here, I'm purely
talking about the way
we interact with the web.
Fediverse is another concept,
this Federated universe
of websites-- that's where
the name comes from--
of, again, decentralized
these ideas.
So Mastodon is a part
of this Fediverse idea.
And there is suite of
tools that are trying
to form the protocols to allow
for and ensure interoperability
between these
websites and concepts.
But it's not going to be
a seamless transition.
But that lack of
seamless transition
should perk your
ears up and say, hey,
what that means is there's
a lot of opportunity.
Every time there's some sort
of ambiguity, uncertainty
of how or what things
will become, especially
in the internet, it has led
to a lot of opportunity.
If we look at Dot Com, then that
was burst-- the Dot Com bubble
burst.
But to some extent, a lot
of jobs and a lot of wealth
was created because
all of a sudden there
was this new tool, the
internet, and nobody
knew what it could be.
All of a sudden, you could sell
books online, or sell products,
or share information.
Well, then we had this
Web2, That's the Web1.
The Web2 is viewed as the
social media movement, where
all of a sudden, well, hey,
what if we could continuously
communicate with everyone
we know, or want to know,
or want to follow?
That opened up so many
doors to the extent
that the vast majority of
the most desirable jobs
still fall, as far
as tech jobs, still
fall within a few
major social media
companies or tech companies.
And so then what does that
mean for this next round
of the internet because
those companies are
struggling right now?
Except for a few
platforms, most of them
are taking a downturn
in user growth.
And so there's this question
of, will they persist,
and will those be the
jobs of the future,
or will there be something else?
And that's where, again,
I want you to think about,
what are the opportunities that
are going to present themselves
there, and where do you want
to be in those opportunities?
Again, open idea, does
not have an answer.
Think about these pros and cons.
Are the pros and cons the
same as with Mastodon,
or there are new
issues that arise
or opportunities
that arise when I
expand to every website
and every service?
Think about a Netflix.
What is a decentralized
Netflix look like?
How do you build that?
Are there any things that
should remain centralized?
Are there some things
that, man, if we
start to decentralize
everything,
we are going to really start
to ruin the experiences
and the opportunities, maybe
the equity of the internet?
And that is really
my last question--
is a decentralized web
more equitable or not?
I think the easy
answer's maybe yes,
the more honest and
difficult answers may be.
So I'll leave that
one as open question.
But these are the ideas I want
you to end this course with
and end thinking about is, what
tools, what skills should I
acquire to not only become
employed today, but also
in perpetuity, or
maybe even create
the next company of the future?
So I'll leave it at that.
We will, for sure,
be in communication.
But let me know if you have any
questions or any issues come up.
And I'll, hopefully,
see you soon.
Bye